welcome everybody welcome back to the
fourth and final lecture in Michael
walls is Stimson lectures on the general
subject of whatever happened to national
liberation we heard two lectures last
week on the paradox of national
liberation the the first outlined this
paradox with by reference to the
discussion of Israel India and Algeria
and the the paradox that concerned
Michel centrally was between the secular
nationalism of national liberation
movements and the fundamentalist
backlash that they subsequently
generated in the second of those
lectures he explored that subject in
much greater depth in the context of
Israel and Palestine and particularly
the the tension between Zionism and
Judaism and its implications not only
for the character of the Israeli state
that has developed but also its
implications for the evolution of
Palestinian nationalism and Palestinian
politics subsequently then yesterday in
true to form Michel anticipated
critiques of his argument from Marxist
and post-colonial critics and in
particular he took on Perry Anderson's
discussion that's was is an implicit
critique of Michael's view his
discussion of Israel India and Ireland
and developed a an anticipatory response
to that to Perry Anderson's argument
which I couldn't possibly summarize with
the eloquence that Michael deployed but
I would to reduce it to to my own
formulation was essentially a version of
the argument that Anderson's critique of
national liberation movements throws the
baby out with the bathwater
and that a a more nuanced and subtle
discussion is needed in order to take
account of the sort of impulses that
those who make these arguments appeal to
in in today's final lecture Michael is
going to talk about the future of
national liberation it's a
disappointment to me only in one sense
and that is that it's the final lecture
I don't know what I remember do next
Wednesday and Thursday afternoon these
are really been stunningly interesting
lectures and we're all going to be
looking forward to the book that will be
forthcoming from Yale University Press
sooner rather than later I hope and
think but so Michael welcome for the
fourth and final lecture in your series
so I I want to thank those of you who
have stuck with me through for four
meetings and today I will I will try to
to offer some answers to the questions
that I've been posing about what
happened and what might happen what
happened to national liberation and what
to do about it
last time I insisted on the difference
between secular national liberation and
religious revivalism against critics who
said that they were actually not so
different and today I want to try to
face again
the paradox of liberation and ask why
the liberationists have not been able to
consolidate their achievement and
reproduce themselves in successive
generations Indian intellectuals and
academics have over the past 20 years
been debating this question in its local
version why is it one of the masks that
the Nehru V envision of
Killer India failed to take hold the
current argument was begun or I first
came upon it in the writing of uh she's
Nandi a longtime critic of both secular
nationalism and Hindutva he's the person
who called them the disowned doubles of
each other and in an article entitled
the politics of secularism and the
recovery of religious toleration nandi
evokes a pre-modern pluralist and
tolerant Hinduism fuzzy and sink
artistic which the militants of national
liberation he says ignored and
suppressed they're secularists and
modernist radicalism produced a
pathological reaction which is
revivalist and also modernist the
modernism is shared having learned from
Western theories of statecraft the
partisans of liberation and the
partisans of religious revival are
equally willing to use the power of the
modern state against their opponents so
nandi's critique of Hindu nationalism
writes the Philosopher's akio bill
gourami is intended to be of a piece
with the critique of Nehru vien
secularism Hindutva itself the product
of modernity owes its very existence to
the oppositional but at the same time
internal dialectical relation it bears
to secularism this isn't a Marxist
internationalist critique but rather an
anti modernist critique and it has
attracted wide support in India from
writers some of whom might best be
identified as latter-day Gundy ins while
others are post modernists and
post-colonial ists nandi argues that
Gandhi's use of Hindu motifs was
justified because his Hinduism was
authentic that is located in traditions
outside the ideological grid of
modernity by
contrast Hindutva is radically
inauthentic Nandi writes mockingly about
the RSS a paramilitary Hindu nationalist
group whatever the revivalist Hindu may
seek to revive it is not Hinduism the
pathetically comic martial uniform of
khaki shorts which the RSS cadres have
to wear tells it all models on the
uniform of the colonial police the khaki
shorts identify the RSS as the
illegitimate child of Western
colonialism Nandi has similar things to
say about the nerubian state which took
upon itself he writes the same
civilizing mission that the colonial
states had once taken upon themselves
visibly the ancient faiths of the
subcontinent that last point is
certainly true it's another example of
the paradox of national liberation but
not one that necessarily carries the
condemnation that Nandi intends in 1829
for example the British banned the sati
the ritual immolation of a Hindu widow
on her husband's funeral pyre and after
independence the new Indian government
reiterated the ban acting out I suppose
the same civilizing mission by contrast
some leading figures of the Hindu
revival have spoken up in defense of
sati and in this case they don't appear
to be inauthentic indeed the difficulty
with nandi's position as his Indian
critics have pointed out is that however
pluralist and tolerant Hinduism may have
been it was also hierarchical and
oppressive especially oppressive to
women
the rise of Hindutva is as much a
response to the egalitarianism of the
liberationists as to their secularism
the hegemony of the brahmanas the
comforts of caste
and the traditional constraints on the
life of women all these are closer to
the heart of the revival and probably
closer to the heart of the pre-modern
religion too then is religious pluralism
for Democrats and liberals then the
ancient faith isn't and shouldn't be on
the political agenda nor should we be
too quick to condemn the impact of
Western modernity and of Western
liberalism on Indian society the
civilizing mission may have been
hypocritical in ideology of imperialism
but it was also sometimes a useful
product of estudar seedot one of the
first presidents of the Indian National
Congress wrote in the early years of
nationalist agitation the right of the
peasants to be educated to be freed from
the trammels of ignorance to be saved
from the oppression of landlords such
ideas have invariably emanated from our
rulers and not from us as I have been
arguing in these lectures national
liberation is the work of men and women
who learned a great deal from their
Imperial rulers and used what they
learned in the interests of liberation
struggling at the same time against
imperialism and also against some of
their own people's most revered customs
and practices the liberationists
retained the structures of the Imperial
state because they believed in the words
of de peche Chakrabarti one of the
leading post-colonial writers they
believed in an Enlightenment rationalism
that requires as its vehicle the modern
state and its accompanying institutions
the instruments of govern ability in
fucose terms but I'm not sure that is a
the critique that Chakravarthi intends
four it's hard to imagine any other
instruments of governability that could
end untouchable the the the persecution
the exclusion of untouchables or lift
the constraints on the lives of women or
protect religious minorities but this
status commitment and this opposition to
their people's customs rights aditya
nagamma colleague of nandi's at the
Center for the Study of developing
societies in New Delhi this commitment
and this opposition were too abstract
it's as if the goal of the liberationist
was not a new Indian man as they claimed
but a universal citizen there is no
concrete cultural content to the
liberationist project nagamma argues and
so the project turned out to be a front
for the continued domination of Brahmin
elites and it's defenders were unable to
offer significant resistance to the
ideologists of Hindutva this argument is
an Indian version of our own megan's
explanation for the failures of zionist
secularism and the rise of religious
zealotry every vacuum must fill up it
isn't a fair argument in the Indian or
the Israeli case in the early years of
Independence the Congress dominated
government undertook a massive
educational effort on behalf of the new
constitution Nehru and his friends
certainly expounded and defended the
liberal values they were trying to
realize so Nandi may be right to claim
that the problem with Nehru vien
secularism wasn't that it was too
abstract but that it was too absolute in
its challenge to Hindu and Muslim
traditionalism it is absolutism that
best accounts for the strength and
militancy of the religious reaction a
number of nandi's critics have made a
similar claim and I want to look a
little longer at their suggestions for
dealing with Hindutva and its defenders
and I will then ask whether a whether
the religious revival in Israel
can be addressed in a similar way the
central problem with with neighbors
politics
according to bill Rami was that his
secularism was Archimedean rather than
negotiated by this the Rami means that
secularism stood outside the substantive
arena of political commitment remember
Archimedes boast that he could move the
universe if only he could stand
somewhere outside it for the national
liberation as secularism was an external
standpoint of this sort from which
Indian society could be moved could be
transformed the secularist project
didn't emerge from society itself
it wasn't the product of internal
arguments and negotiations as nijam
rights Hindu and Muslim orthodoxy was
never defeated in open battle in society
at large and the reason that secularism
wasn't negotiated or openly fought for
is that Nehru and his associates were
unwilling bill graeme claims to
acknowledge the existence of religious
communities and communitarian
commitments but why the unwillingness
here there's a deep tension in the
liberationist position or attention come
and I think to all the other national
liberation movements on the one hand
neighbor who did not believe that the
religious communities had a had a future
religious belief or at least it's more
fervent and superstitious virgin
versions would vanish at the touch of
reality
after independence neighbor wrote in the
discovery of India there would be class
conflicts but no religious conflicts
except insofar as religion itself
expressed some vested interest he meant
some economic interest one has to wonder
what India he had discovered but in fact
this faith of the decline of faith was
as I argued in the first of these
lectures widely shared on the other hand
Nehru knew very well the strain
to both Hinduism and Islam and he
certainly understood the near identity
of the caste and economic hierarchies so
his refusal to recognize the religious
communities wasn't determined so much by
blindness as by fear to recognize them
he said would be to encourage and
entrench them I suppose that these two
views can be held simultaneously
religious identity is a clear and
present danger while secularization
however inevitable lies somewhere in the
future still these are different views
and in the Indian case the difference
was acted out in a very special way on
the assumption that the erosion of
belief was at least begun and could be
speeded up and that vested interests had
to be confronted the new Indian state
set out to reform Hindu laws and
practices the Constitution written
written immediately after independence
abolished untouchability and banned
discrimination on the basis of religion
or caste over the next decade Parliament
established a single code of personal
law for all hindu citizens they acted
with a slowness and reluctance that
infuriated Ambedkar the untouchable
activist who was neighbors first
minister of justice but they acted the
new code permitted inter caste marriage
legalized divorce prohibited polygamy
gave daughter's the same inheritance
rights as sons and and much more the aim
of the liberationists partha chatterjee
rights was to initiate a process of
rational interpretation of religious
doctrine in fact what they were doing
was denying the name religious to much
of what was traditionally understood as
religious doctrine according to the new
constitution every community had the
right to manage its own affairs in
matters of religion but state officials
insisted on
a narrow definition of religion or at
least a narrow definition of Hinduism I
do not understand Ambedkar wrote why
religion should be given a vast
expansive jurisdiction so as to cover
the whole of life the proper coverage
was limited to beliefs and worship
everything beyond that fell within the
jurisdiction of the state after all
Ambedkar continues what is this Liberty
for the point of Independence was to
reform our social system which is full
of inequalities and discrimination all
this was said with regard to Hinduism
for what were probably good reasons
however there was no similar effort to
restrict the reach of Islam and
establish a recognized rationalized
system of personal law for the Muslim
minority Nehru and his associates were
not ready to challenge the strength of
Islamic belief and the authority of
Sharia for the majority there would be
liberation for the minority there would
be religious liberty with Islam allowed
precisely the vast expansive
jurisdiction that Ambedkar was so eager
to deny to Hinduism in effect there was
no negotiation with either religious
community state officials decided
top-down to reform Hindu law and to
tolerate Muslim law from the
liberationist standpoint this was
greatly to the advantage of the Hindus
the socialist leader JB Kripalani argued
that if the members of parliament single
out the Hindu community for their
reforming zeal they cannot escape the
charge of being communalist in the sense
that they favor the Hindus and are
indifferent to the good of the Muslims
Hindu traditionalists made exactly the
opposite charge claiming that it was the
Muslims who were being favored in any
event top-down reform was only partially
successful
so the favoritism was live
when India won its independence rights
Harold Isaac's all Untouchables became
ex Untouchables by law but they remained
Untouchables in fact that that isn't
quite right an extensive program of
affirmative action opened new
opportunities to younger members of what
had come to be called at the insistence
of untouchable militants the delete'
community of the oppressed community
Hindutva as I've already said is in part
a reaction to the special treatment
reserved offices and welfare benefits
accorded to both the untouchables and
the lowest castes a practice that has
the simultaneous effect of maintaining
caste lines post modernist writers say
that it essential eise's caste while
threatening the traditional caste
hierarchy these are the ambiguities of
liberation they are perhaps especially
clear in the case of Hindu and Muslim
women the former the beneficiaries of
the new civil code the latter still
ruled by Islamic personal law in a
famous court case shibano in 1985 the
judges sought to extend the protection
of the civil code to a divorced
Muslim wife but Parliament undid the
decision with the new Muslim women Act
in 1986 who was being favored here from
the standpoint of Hindu nationalists the
new legislation was yet another example
of the Indian state in the Congress
party bending over backward to favor the
Muslim minority which was again allowed
to maintain its traditional practices by
contrast the All India Democratic
Women's Association and other feminist
groups which are the true heirs of
national liberation insisted rightly
that the new law was no favor to Muslim
women in March of 1986 35 women's
organizations including Muslim groups
joined together to demonstrate for
uniform secular code which was the
original promise of Nehru and his
associates I cannot I can't pursue these
issues and he further my knowledge of
Indian history and politics doesn't
reach to their complexities I only want
to insist that through all the
compromises and confusions of political
practice since 1947 it is still possible
to mark clearly the difference between
secular liberation and both traditional
and revivalists religion I suspect that
the differences are most clear with
regard to the subordination of women it
is the demand for gender equality that
poses the greatest challenge to
traditional religion and is I suspect
the most important cause are certainly
one of the centrally important causes of
revivalist zealotry in all three of my
cases certainly the members of the All
India Democratic Women's Association
whose name suggests a national project
all India are in no sense the twins or
the secret doubles of the Hindutva
militants
nor does neighbor whose decision in the
40s to allow religious liberty to the
Muslim minority in the field of family
law make him a twin of Muslim
traditionalists despite the happiness of
the mullahs with the legal recognition
of Sharia both these pears Democratic
women and Hindutva militants Nehru vien
liberals and Muslim traditionalists are
in fact long-term political opponents
but by what means should this opposition
be pursued
what do Indian critics of neighbors
Archimedean politics mean when they call
for a negotiated secularism in October
2004 the socialist magazine Janata
reported on a conference in New Delhi on
the condition of Muslim women
the conferees included feminist
activists and male members of the Muslim
Personal Law Board naturally the two
groups disagreed but what was most
interesting was that and I'm now quoting
the magazine numerous women participants
argued from within an Islamic paradigm
quoting verse after verse from the Quran
and citing traditions attributed to the
Prophet to make their case for gender
justice these women were a new force
says that you're not the janata reporter
they had the moral authority that
feminists who are seen as alienated from
their societies and traditions lack the
same claim can be made I think for the
members of a group called women living
under Muslim laws WL UML doesn't make a
nice acronym a feminist organization
founded in the 1980s by women from a
number of Muslim majority countries
including importantly Algeria whose work
has reached to India where the Muslims
are a very large minority the members of
WL UML are both religious and secular
and one of their central goals is to
provide reinterpretations of Muslim laws
relating to the status of women the
plural form laws is important to this
project they insist that there are
different understandings and different
enactments what is always described as
Quranic law so women now can join an
argument that doesn't have what the
religious zealots insist on a single
authoritative conclusion delivered by
learned men by joining the argument
rather than standing outside it they
hope to win at least a hearing from
religious Muslims men and women alike if
they are learned it as many of them are
they can also be authoritative a Marcus
Sen lays claim
the same kind of moral authority for
Democrats in pluralists when he argues
that ideas of public debate and respect
for religious difference have roots in
ancient Indian thought and provides many
examples his argument is different from
nandi's though some of his examples
might serve them both sin claims that
important modernist ideas are not
modernist inventions they were expressed
long ago though in different idioms they
are part of a common heritage that may
have to be selectively rejected but that
can also be selectively reclaimed it may
well be the case that the best arguments
for gender justice and for democratic
pluralism our secular and philosophical
and character but philosophy doesn't
rule the day here the best moral and
political arguments are ones that derive
from the inherited culture of the people
who need to be convinced engagement with
that culture is what neighbors critics
mean by negotiation they argue that
secularism in the West derives from a
political negotiation with Protestant
Christianity and so they imagine
internal arguments that might produce
Hindu and Muslim versions of secular
doctrine and also of democratic
egalitarian and feminist doctrines
Oommen Narayan an Indian woman working
at in the United States has worked out a
theoretical version of these arguments
in her book dislocating cultures
identities traditions and third world
feminism she takes on the charge that
demands for gender equality represent a
capitulation to the cultural domination
of a colonizing West
now as Marx's articles these famous
articles on India show this charge can
also be a boast all good modern ideas
come from the historically advanced
countries of the West and it is
certainly true as I have shown in these
lectures that many leaders of the
national liberation movements were
westernizers but Narayan argues for two
important caveats here with special
reference to what was once called the
woman question first when the liberation
movements began in late 19th century
India for example gender equality was
hardly a dominant ideology in the West
and second Indian feminists can
plausibly argue that their struggle for
equality and I'm quoting Narayan now is
no less rooted in our experiences within
our culture's no less representative of
our complex and changing reality than
the views of Indians hostile to feminism
liberation as I suggested last time
yesterday liberation is a reiterative
process it doesn't happen once for
everybody in the world it happens again
and again but that doesn't mean that
each successive struggle is nothing more
than an imitation of the struggle that
went before yes many Indian feminists
did learn their feminism in the West
remember the oxford education of
Rajkumari Amrit tower but they also made
it their own in the course of their
engagement with their indian sisters the
Ryan's book goes well beyond claiming
that feminism has Indian roots she
argues for the cultivation of those
roots she makes a very strong case for a
connected and so to speak naturalized
feminism that is a feminism that is
embedded in national narratives and
religious traditions let me quote one
summary statement of her position which
comes very close to the position I have
meant to defend in these lectures it
would be dangerous she writes for
feminists to attempt to challenge
prevailing views of religion and
religious tradition purely by resort to
secularism many religious traditions are
in fact more capacious than
fundamentalist adherents allow insisting
on humane and inclusive interpretations
of these traditions might in many
contexts be crucial encountering the
deployment of religious discourse for
problematic nationalists ends this this
isn't an argument about stooping to
conquer narayan rights movingly about
the importance of national and religious
commitments in the life of ordinary men
and women shaping their sense of who
they are and their understanding of the
social world she's arguing for an honest
and compassionate engagement with these
men and women there are of course
pragmatic political reasons for such an
engagement refusing it will as she says
marginalize progressive and feminist
voices whose political interventions in
the discourse of nationalism are
increasingly crucial but there are also
democratic reasons for this engagement
narayan quotes virginia woolf's
anti-nationalist lines from 1938 as a
woman i have no country as a woman i
want no country as a woman my country is
the whole world virginia woolf must have
read as i never suspected her of doing
marks on the working class Narayan
argues on the contrary that women do
have a country and they share a fate
with their fellow citizens who need to
hear their voice traditionalist
worldviews can't be negated abolished or
banned they have to be engaged I've made
this argument several times in these
lectures it may not be an argument
useful to or even accessible to the
liberation militants at the height of
their struggle against the old religion
and the culture of passivity and
subservience only a few intellectuals
aimed at engagement in those years and
they didn't get much support neighbor
who may have regarded his discovery of
India as an example of engagement and
what he discovered in Indian history is
impressive an ancient complex and
multicultural composite civilization he
even claimed to have found that quote
bad as the legal position of women was
in ancient India judged by modern
standards
it was far better than in ancient Greece
and Rome in early Christianity in the
canon law of medieval Europe and indeed
right up to comparatively modern times
but with regard to the religious
traditions that played such a large part
in shaping Indian civilization and in
determining the customary roles of women
Nehru was mostly tone-deaf his discovery
or maybe it's an invention of a
civilization wonderfully attractive to
secular intellectuals bear some
resemblance to the Zionist discovery or
invention of biblical Israel neither one
came to grips with the actual religious
beliefs and practices of the people who
had to be liberated maybe that wasn't
possible maybe it was necessary first to
lay down the secular law as Nehru and
Ambedkar did in the new Indian
Constitution and Civil Code and only
when these turn out to be incompletely
effective and when they provoke a
religious reaction do the engagements
and negotiations have to begin so this
is the question that secular liberals
and Democrats must face
how can National Liberation make itself
central to the ongoing life of the
nation how can it regain and sustain its
political hegemony and this is this is
the the deepest question that I mean to
raise in these lectures and which the
Indian writers I've just
and quoting have begun to address what
has gone wrong with and what are the
obstacles to the cultural reproduction
of let's call it the secular left
liberation cannot succeed hegemony
cannot be sustained by negation alone
that's the beginning of an answer to
these questions the fact of hegemony
rights Antonio Gramsci its foremost
theorist presupposes that one takes into
account the interests and tendencies of
the groups over which hegemony will be
exercised and it also presupposes a
certain equilibrium that is to say that
the hegemonic groups will make some
sacrifices fierce and unrelenting
hostility may be crucial to the
liberation movements initial initial
mobilization and it necessarily figures
also in secular responses to the
traditionalist counter-revolution but it
isn't a creative force it doesn't take
the interests of traditional Hindus
Muslims and Jews into account and it
doesn't move toward the required
equilibrium so consider now the Zionist
case I'm going to conclude here since
this is the case with which I am myself
most engaged in Israel it seems clear
that the negation of exilic Judaism has
failed and that's the leap to the
biblical past and other efforts to find
usable bits and pieces of the tradition
serve only to produce a Jewish Kitsch
which cannot compete with a revived
Judaism the claim to a radical newness
gives rise inexorably to a radicalized
old Necedah ism as with Hinduism and
Islam it is possible that the old old
miss was in fact more pluralistic more
accepting of difference
in practice if not in doctrine then
either the secular liberationists
imagined or the religious zealots admit
maybe but I don't think that nostalgia
is any more attractive in Israel than in
India there is indeed much that needed
to be and still needs to be negated the
fearfulness and passivity of traditional
Judaism the dominance of the rabbi's the
subordination of women but alongside the
ongoing work of negation the tradition
has to be acknowledged and it's
different parts in gathered as the poet
Bialik argued collected translated
incorporated into the culture of the new
only then can traditional Judaism be
pulled apart if that's what people want
to do historical its most important
features laws and Maxim ceremonies and
practices historical and fictional
narratives critically appraised and only
then can those features be accepted or
rejected or revised only then can they
become the subject of an ongoing
argument and negotiation it is argument
itself with its varying outcomes that
constitutes the Grampian equilibrium
not any single or final balance of
acceptance and rejection one can be a
very radical critic of the religious
tradition as I would be while still
taking account of its value for the
Jewish people or for the Indian or the
Algerian people but the commitment to
take account means that one must learn
something about the world of one's
traditionalists opponents the opposite
of negation is not acceptance but again
intellectual and political engagement
since Zionism is a political movement
the most obvious area of engagement is
politics itself but Zionists negation
was first of all a denial that there was
a Jewish politics in the Exile or even a
collective Jew
history here's ben-gurion since our last
national tragedy he's referring to the
suppression of the Bar Kokhba rebellion
in the year 135 of the Common Era since
our last national tragedy we have had
histories of persecution of legal
discrimination of the Inquisition and
pogroms of martyrdom but we have not had
a Jewish history because of the history
of a people is only what the people
create as a whole and the Jews according
to ben-gurion created nothing in the
centuries of Exile in fact the internal
politics of the Jewish Diaspora through
which the people as a whole sustained
itself in scattered communities without
course of power for many centuries is
one of the more remarkable stories in
the political history of humankind
exilic politics was in its decadence
when the Zionists arrived on the scene
and had never been valued within the
tradition itself committed to deference
and deferment dreaming of a distant
triumph the rabbi's have little to say
about the success of the semi-autonomous
communities of the Diaspora and they
took no interest in the political
lessons that might be drawn from it this
could have provided an opening for
Zionists writers but they found the
decadence of Jewish communal life a more
useful subject and made no effort to
overcome they're ignorant of its better
days for some of them indeed ignorance
of exilic history since it wasn't a real
national history was a matter of
principle I've got how I'm at least
acknowledged the better days the
rabbinic sages he wrote succeeded in
creating a national body which hung in
midair without any foundation on solid
earth and in this body the Hebrew
national spirit has had its abode and
lived its life for 2,000 years
but the real achievement of exilic
jewelry marvelous and unique as Kadam
said was to lose the singularity of this
body and still survive in scattered
fragments all living one form of life
and all United
despite their local separateness these
fine words were apparently not
inspirational I have not found in the
literature of Zionism any discovery of
the old Jewish communities I mean any
extended effort to understand how exilic
politics worked or to honor the people
who made it work or to value the
achievement the laws customs practices
and implicit understandings that made
the communal life of the Exile possible
surely this is material for in gathering
and then for appreciation and critique
by a movement aiming at a new birth of
communal life indeed the experience of
exile and then of emancipation in exile
might well teach contemporary Israelis
something of great importance how
different Jewish communities could
coexist within the framework of a
secular state alongside other non-jewish
religious communities the new Israeli
majority might learn a lot from the
experience of the old Jewish minorities
another obvious place for engagement as
in India and Algeria is with the
traditional subordination of women which
took different forms in Judaism than it
did in Hinduism and in Islam never
reaching for example to the radical
seclusion of the perda
but still mandating the exclusion of
women from public religious and
political life the liberationists
commitment to create a new man was also
a commitment to create a new woman set
free from her traditionally required
submission to patriarchal Authority the
actual standing of women in the kibbutz
movement in the Hagana and then in the
Israeli army
didn't and doesn't always accord with
liberationists ideology but the
ideological position is clear in the new
nation-state there would be gender
equality I've already described how
religious revival challenges the very
idea of equality and have surprised that
unprepared the liberationists were for
the willingness of many women to return
to orthodoxy and accept a version of the
old subordination they are almost
equally surprised by the fierceness of
the religious zealots attack on gender
equality even in the Israeli army which
has been one of the prime instruments of
liberationists transformation and
something of a sacred cow to mix my
cases in Israeli politics the Galit
Aryan argument seems obvious to me but
it's also obvious that simply reciting
the argument isn't sufficient today
there are religious women in every
denomination of Judaism arguing for
equality in the language of the
tradition and producing wonderfully
subtle and intellectually engaging
reinterpretations of both the Bible and
the Talmud it may be a sign of the
polarization produced by secularists and
zealots in Israel that a great deal of
the early feminists interpretive work
was not done there but in the Diaspora
indeed much of the religious energy
among American Jews today comes from
women who make up a growing number of
ordained rabbis needless to say nothing
similar is going on in Israel where
secular Jewish women aren't interested
in becoming rabbis and religious women
wouldn't dream of it though some I think
are beginning to dream perhaps there is
a pattern here
the central office of women living under
Muslim laws is not an Algeria or an any
Muslim majority country but it is in
London and the Marquis and I'll Akhil
with Romney and uma Narayan eloquent
critics of Archimedean secularism in
India live in the United States the men
and women who reclaim tradition while
also criticizing it they are some
resemblance to the early leaders of
national liberation who also live for
long periods of time outside the
countries they meant to liberate but
arguments for a critical engagement with
the tradition will make their way home
at least they have some chance of
appealing to men and women who tire of
the radical polarity of negation and
revival in all three of my cases we can
begin to see writers and activists
struggle struggling to occupy the space
between the polls in Israel and I
suspect in India and Algeria to the
clearest examples come from the academic
world the project of critical engagement
has not yet found what is most necessary
to its success a strong political
expression I haven't meant to argue in
these lectures that the traditionalist
counter-revolution could have been
avoided the paradox of national
liberation overcome had the Zionists a
fully engaged the tradition from the
beginning but a full-scale engagement
early on might have made for a stronger
response to the counter-revolution than
anything forthcoming today it might have
provided Zionism with a more elaborated
a more interesting and a more democratic
culture and it might have improved the
odds it might still improve the odds for
the eventual success of Jewish national
liberation this suggests of you that has
become more and more appealing to me as
I have worked on these three cases
national liberation like every other
form of liberation is a very long
process not a single battle but a series
of battles that extends a
for many decades despite the engagement
of religious zealots this process is
secular in two senses of the word as the
dictionary defines the word liberation
is a worldly process and it is of
indefinite duration its secular in
another sense to its outcome is not
determined by faith not by religious
faith and not by the ideological version
either the early liberationists believed
that their struggle had a singular and
certain end but the critical engagement
with religious beliefs and practices is
liberating in a new way now the end is
open radically uncertain or better the
process is unendingly various the tasks
of men and women committed to national
liberation is to sustain their
engagement with the traditions of their
nation and at the same time their fierce
opposition to all the versions of
traditionalists passivity and oppression
now I've always disliked lectures and
writers who end by telling other people
what their task is but since the task
that I've just described has also been
my own task in these lectures I don't
mind recommending it to any of you who
share my conviction that many nations
including these three still need to be
liberated thank you